stop comparing yourself to other people
people say get don't touch the financing
sector because it's illegal you may be
in prison well put me in the prison
let's make a shirt that Ali pay the
payment solution works have you ever
bought a technology company no I really
haven't
in 30 years of investing not one I
haven't understood any of them I wanna
be happy
build a life not just a business
everybody every single day
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the top lessons from
billionaire entrepreneurs enjoy okay
let's kick it off with lesson number one
master your craft with Oprah Winfrey the
number one lesson I could offer you
where your work is concerned as this
becomes so skilled so vigilant so
flat-out fantastic at what you do that
your talent cannot be dismissed stop
comparing yourself to other people
[Applause]
you're only on this planet to be you not
someone else's imitation of you I had to
learn that the hard way on the air live
anchoring the news one night in my 20s
when I first started broadcasting I was
19
moved to an anchor by the time I was 20
and I was just pretending to be Barbara
Walker Walters I was just trying to talk
like Barbara acting like Bravo Barbara
hold my legs like Barbara and I was on
the air and I hadn't read the copy fully
and I called Canada Canada and I did
that on the air I crack myself up
because I thought Barbara would never
call Canada Canada and that little break
through that little crack that little
moment that I stopped pretending allowed
the real me to come through your life
journey is about learning to become more
of who you are and fulfilling the
highest truest expression of yourself as
a human being that's why you're here
lesson number two be willing to make
sacrifices with Elon Musk well I mean
Tesla really faced this fear threat
threat of death due to the model 3
production ramp essentially the company
was bleeding money like crazy and and
just if we didn't solve these problems
in a very short period of time we would
die
and was extremely difficult to solve
them how close to death did you come we
get everything single digit weeks 22
hours a day I think what I mean I was
working answer seven days a week
sleeping in the factory worked their way
from the I worked in the paint shop
general assembly body shop you ever
worry about yourself imploding like it
just yeah absolutely
no one should put the spenny hours into
work this is not good
a pill should not work this hard I'd and
what they should not do this it was very
painful painful in what sense it's
because my hurts my brain in my heart
hurts this is not recommended for anyone
I just did it because if I didn't do it
and has a good chance of a diet also if
you want to have more confidence check
out my 254 series it's free the link to
join is in the description below they
think that success is supposed to happen
like that there are times when if
something is important enough you
believe it enough but you do you do it
in spite of the fear if everything has
to work in two to three years then that
limits what you can do lesson number
three choose to do hard things with Jeff
Bezos we all have adversity in our lives
yeah III would I would I doubt if you
really you know if you know somebody any
friend or anybody that you talk to
there's no lack of adversity and the and
by the way that's good
because it's what teaches us how to get
back up you fall down you get back up it
always happens and you know you get
certain gifts in life and you want to
take advantage of those but you like
it's my advice on adversity and success
would be to be proud not of your gifts
but of your hard work and your choices
so you know you may be the kinds of
gifts you get like you know you might be
really good at math it might be really
easy for you that's a kind of gift
but practicing that math and taking it
to the next step that could be very
challenging and hard and take a lot of
sweat that's a choice you can't really
be proud of your gifts because they were
given to you you can be grateful for
them and thankful for them and but your
choices you choose to work hard you
choose to do hard things those are
choices that you can be proud of lesson
number four solve big problems with Jack
Ma we are not a company that normally
China collar we call ourself accompanied
running a platform a company that is
running an ecosystem we are almost
everywhere people say Jack you know you
are in the b2b and b2c and you're
calling C to be on a finance and online
payment logistic cloud computing you are
everywhere not because we're greedy not
because we want to do it because we have
to do it if we cannot if we do not a do
it China
economist in the years were collapse I
remember nine years ago when I started
that Ali pay people say yet don't touch
the financing sector because it's
illegal you may be in prison and I we
taught our self if we don't do it the
China ecommerce were always like a like
a chat room everybody said it's a good
thing and yeah I don't pay you don't get
the things so I say well put me in the
prison let's make a shirt that Ali pay
the payment solution works and people
say the payment solution is such a
stupid idea it's an escrow service I pay
you hold of money and you get the things
you pay the money if you don't get the
things you want return the money they
say it's a stupid product and I say as
long as you solve the problem
I like stupid things you know let's make
stupid things smart keep on improving
every day and listen number five the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is stick to your area of expertise
with Warren Buffett I don't need to be
in Washington to figure out what the
Washington Post
newspaper is work and I don't need to be
in New York to figure out what some
other company is work that's it's simply
it's an intellectual process and unless
the law static there is in that land
election process really the better off
you are
what is the intellectual process
intellectual processes is defining your
level defining your area of competence
and valuing businesses and then within
that area of competence finding whatever
sells at the cheapest price in relation
to value and there are all kinds of
things I'm not competent to value well
there are few that I am competent to
value have you ever bought a technology
company no I really haven't
in 30 years of investing not one I
haven't understood any of them so you
haven't ever owned for example IBM
whenever I want I glam moiré company I
made a sensational company but I haven't
known IBM and so here is this
technological revolution going on and
you're not gonna bits artistical right
to ask me is that all right with you
it's okay with me I don't have to make
money in every game I mean I don't know
what cocoa beans are gonna do I don't
know I there are all kinds of things I
don't know about and that may be too bad
but you know why should I know all about
them haven't worked that hard on them in
securities business you literally every
day have thousands of the major American
corporations offered you at a price and
a price that changes daily and you don't
have to make any decisions you have to
make that nothing is forced upon you so
you there are no called strikes in the
business the pitcher just stands there
and throws balls at you and if you're
playing real baseball and that's between
the knees and the shoulders you either
swing or you got a strike caller I need
to get too many calls I knew you're out
in the securities business you sit there
and they throw us steal a 25 and they
throw Journal Motors at 68 you don't
have to swing at any of them they may be
wonderful pitches to swing at but if you
don't know enough you don't have to
swing and you can sit there and watch
thousands of pitches and finally you get
one right there where you want it
something that you understand and then
you swing and so you find that swing for
six months might not swing for two years
now got a special bonus tip with Mark
Zuckerberg on how to be proud of what
you do but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go question number one
what is your greatest area of expertise
number two what big problem are you
trying to solve and number three what
hard thing will you choose to do if
we've given the world of voice look at
what's happened in the last year you've
had elections in last year's elections
manipulated hate speech that's gone
viral and turned offline it certainly
seems like this mission has been
accomplished in many ways and and
there's a whole new set of problems that
perhaps you guys didn't foresee and now
we're in a very complicated place where
there's not an easy solution yeah
there's these are complex issues that
you can't fix you manage them on an
ongoing basis but look do you think that
the world is better with everyone having
a voice and having the ability to
express their opinion and being able to
connect to who they want I don't think
we're going back to a world where there
were just a handful of gatekeepers who
got to control what ideas get expressed
and even if I think that even if we
could well what I'm trying to make it so
we're not I mean that's why making it so
that we're building these independent
governance mechanisms and things like
that are really important and that's
that's work that I did I really care
about but I think that the world will
keep on moving in this direction people
will more people will keep on getting a
voice I think that that's good and and
and and I think there are certainly
going to be issues that we need to work
through over time but I think that while
we are doing that we can't lose sight of
all of the really positive things that
are that are happening here as well not
just in terms of communities and people
being able to to connect with with
groups that are really meaningful to
them whether it's around a disease or or
a community around veterans that they
wouldn't be able to connect to otherwise
but even if you just think about the
economic impact of what we're doing you
know we serve 80 million small
businesses around the world about half
of them have told us that they're hiring
people because of using our tools and
that without Facebook and the tools that
we that we provide and that they that
their business would be significantly
smaller and they wouldn't be hiring as
many people as they are so you know a
study came out the US economy added
about four and a half million jobs over
the
steer if you just look at like what
people are telling us the small
businesses who use our tools we've
directly been able to contribute to
creating many more jobs than that across
the world so I think that this is the
power of giving people a voice giving
small businesses giving communities
giving everyone everywhere the ability
to connect with the people who who they
care about and get their opinion across
and giving everyday people the power
that previously only big companies would
have had so that's the world was gonna
go more in that direction and I think by
and large that's a good thing so I'm
really proud of the work that we're
doing on this and we there are big
issues and I'm not trying to to say that
there aren't that we need to work
through but I do think that sometimes
you can you can get the flavor from a
lot of this from from some of the
coverage that that that's all there is
and and I don't think that that's right
either we need to make sure that we
address these these questions these are
really big and important things for the
future of our society in the future of
the internet but we also need to keep
pushing in the direction of empowering
more people because that's good
if you want to learn more lessons from
Elon Musk Warren Buffett and other
billionaire entrepreneurs check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I can remember coming
home from school me like dad dad I tried
out for this and I was horrible it he'd
be like way to go and high-five